hallo mein name ist luca und da meine
lieblings youtube auch mal ihre videos
vor einem regal aufnimmt habe ich mir
jetzt gedacht dass ich das auch machen
vielleicht bekomme ich dann ist auch
viele abonnenten aber meine damen
bereits im titel gelesen und zwar geht
es heute um eine ebay mystery boards ja
da kann man schon mal klatschen lassen
hat er keinen haribo drin habe ich auch
erst ganz kurz zur erklärung was das
überhaupt ist es gibt bei ebay
verschiedene boxen die man sich
bestellen kann und da packen leute dann
einfach irgendwelche sachen rein
vielleicht ist ja auch eine bombe drin
das war gar nicht mal so geil wenn ich
sagen euch auf machen würde
es gibt verschiedene größen bei diesen
boxen beziehungsweise verschiedene
preisklassen sage ich jetzt mal dass
jeweils die kreisstraße 25 euro das geht
glaube ich hoch bis 300 euro
also wenn ihr bock gehabt dass ich mir
meine teurere mystery box bestelle dann
schreibt für die kommentare und knapp 50
ausgleich vielleicht gefällt euch auch
gar nicht geht erst wenn das video
vorbei ist weil sonst ist es ja blöd
habe ich will gar nicht wohl aber an
freunde ich bin auf jeden fall schon
mega hype was uns in dieser box sie
erwarten wird deswegen würde ich jetzt
sagen als wir machen die box hier
einfach mal drauf und wir sehen schon
das erste was wir uns darin bin meine
kleine krippe mit bastelbogen also das
ist ja so ein büchlein und da ist meine
kleine grippe drin und dies beschrieben
und darin ist auch ein bastelbogen dass
man sich das quasi ihr ausreisen kann
und sich eine eigene krippe bauen kann
dieses büchlein kostet sage und schreibe
2 euro 50
das ist also die erste sache die uns
darin erwartet haben die nächste sache
die werde ich bereue es jetzt schon dass
ich mir diese scheiß box bestellt aber
wir haben hier 800 milliampere batterien
und zwar solche die kosten 21 euro was
die ganze box hat 25 euro gekostet hatte
als kleiner scheißer einer sonst bot und
daher die braucht durch batterien und
damit mit dem spiel gott immer so rum
gefahren aber so sehen und so ich war
immer der coolste die ganzen [ __ ]
abgrund mit einem kleinen boot also
bisherige ausbeute ist das keine krippe
buch und eine 800 minis
was wir drin aber ich hab's noch nicht
anguckt ist das hier wollen die mich
einen kolben ist es ein kolben kupfer
kern das synchron oder was soll ich denn
damit
und warum kostet fünf euro ihr müsst
euch das mal überlegen ich bezahle 25
euro für diese komplette box mit mega
vielen sachen drin und diese batterie
kommt schon 22 euro plus das hier sind
es 24 euro plus das sind 29 euro ich
bekomme mehr als ich bezahle das ist
eigentlich ganz geil ich weiß allerdings
noch nicht was ich hiermit soll hiermit
sollen hiermit soll also bisher allesamt
nicht ausgepackt hatten eigentlich hart
unnötig aber vielleicht erwartet uns
hier drin ja noch großes glück und zwar
als ich weiß nicht was das ist
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist die
sache ist dass diese pakete ja auch von
irgendwelchen leuten willkürlich
zusammengepackt werden und dann ich mir
nur so wo kriegen die diese sachen
überhaupt her wo kauft ihr denn ein
nächstes produkt was wir hier raus
ziehen ist sind wie käpt'n sharky ja
danke für die sticker meter gegenstand
der sich darin versteckt und dem wir
rausholen ist das hier habt ihr noch
nicht anguckt ist das gleiche
unternehmen wie diese komischen gegangen
da sieben euro kostet das uns war es
dass irgendein maschinenteil was klingt
also packen das ganze jetzt mal aus das
ist ein tape was ich jetzt hier so
abziehen kann hier vorne und das kann
dass das ist schon ein bisschen älter
glaube ich also ich kann das hier so
abziehen kann das so abziehen es klebt
und dann kann ich das so mir an die nase
kleben
cool oder nächstes produkt freuen da wir
gleich mal wieder ganz tief rein hier
ist das sind die risse von dem sticker
den jemals nächstes mal dass hier
mutter phang hey was soll das das ist
wahrscheinlich von irgendwelchen
riesigen lackiermaschine ein kleines
teil oder so also ich habe echt ein plan
was ich mit dem bisherigen sachen das
soll die hast ja auch nicht mal
irgendwie zusammen aber batterien mal
was ganz neu ist das dritte mal
batterien brauche ich auch nicht mies
dagegen standen meine damen und herren
ist papier ob ich liebe papier als
nächstes haben wir hier fordert oder
kann ja immer warum die mir jetzt jemand
was was ein bisschen schwerer stw haribo
neues endlich mal was was nicht
gebrauchen kann neben dagegen schon
meine damen und herren haben wir hier
was verteilerkappen
hey verteilerkappen wofür soll ich das
brauche und nächstes produkt meine damen
und herren haben wir hier vorne wieder
irgend so ein teil von einer riesigen
maschine irgendwas wahrscheinlich
wirklich freuen ich möchte überhaupt
nicht undankbar klingen oder so aber ich
habe hierfür halt geld bezahlt 25 euro
und dachte wenigstens das ja in welche
coolen sachen drin sind stattdessen habe
ich erwarte wäre um das nächste produkt
wir haben noch ein kupfer gern oder
zünden ich weiß nicht kann ich habe mich
nicht so gut aus aber das ist wirklich
nur kompletter schwachsinn drin und
alles irgendwie von der gleichen mag
irgendwie die gleichen batterien die
ganze zeit das alles von beruf und
dieser marke dann irgendwelche
maschinenteile das coolste waren bisher
die süßigkeiten nächstes produkt freunde
wir haben noch mal süßigkeiten eis und
ihr habt wohl noch mal süßigkeiten also
so langsam geht das ganze in eine ganz
schöne richtung ich mal wieder ein
bisschen tiefer rein und wir haben ein
alter die geht mich
aber es ist eine taschenlampe liga das
ist neue session lampen sind eigentlich
völlig unterbewertet das ist megageil
eine taschenlampe dabei zu haben wenn
man nachts unterwegs ist oder irgendwie
oder keine ahnung oder vielleicht sogar
gerade als mädchen eigentlich ganz gut
weil böse leute auf dieser welt finde
ich auf jeden fall weiß also danke für
die tasche wie sie sagen ich danke ich
habe dafür bezahlt
bitte für meine 25 euro und danke für
nichts nächster gegenstand haben wir
hier papier ich glaube das ist nur
einfach stoff papier also ich glaube
nicht dass er das deswegen da eingepackt
hat dann haben wir hier noch mehr papier
tatsächlich das haben wir als nächsten
gegenstand hip hop für kinder fast
regenbogen heißt es das ist ja
wundervoll
das kann ich mir dann auch mal selbst
theoretisch in die haare machen magath
neues feiere ich übertrieben ist der
nächste gegenstand dieser 25 euro
mystery box von ebay freunde sind mal
wieder batterien oh wow ich liebe
batterien als nächstes produkt haben wir
vorne ein
da kann auch nix ist aber die gleiche
marke nichts gegen euch aber was macht
man damit also vielleicht haben die an
richtig großen sinn und sind toll für
leute die irgendwie weiter eins muss ich
hier fast kurzen weil die ausbeute so
kacke ist leichter die teile engen
tieferen sinn ich weiß es nicht aber ich
glaube einfach ehrlich gesagt eher nicht
nächstes produkt was hier vorne drin
haben ich war ein bisschen sogar der
dritte kupfer kern freunde bald ihr
kennt ja meinen shop können kunden am
ersten sechs kommen neue atemberaubende
produkte in den shops auf die scheiß auf
die t-shirts auf die quali auf die
neuesten sachen es kommen drei kupfer
kerne limitiert es gibt nur drei stück
freunde wird wirklich ganz klein freuen
und da kommen ganz viele sachen aber ich
würde sagen
so kann er sie ausgeblendet werden weil
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt was er hier drin haben ich nicht
raus moment moment regie so geil
zwischen stecker mit usb ladeanschluss
wow das ist tatsächlich eigentlich ganz
nice und zwar steckt man das in die
steckdose und hat dann einerseits an der
steckdose hat an eine steckdose und an
da kann man also summa summarum look
zeigen nächstes produkt was wir hier
vorne drin haben meine damen und herren
ich dachte ich habe elektrischer
bekommen doch das war meine spieler die
mich gebissen hat ja also ich weiß nicht
was das hier darstellen soll das ist
irgendwie wahrscheinlich wieder so ein
teil unserer größeren maschine ich weiß
noch nicht wo die person die sachen
einkaufte da vielleicht arbeitet er dort
in der industrie im und habe ich als
erstes produkt freunde mal das war da
drin das ist dann rausgefallen
ja das war eine menge staub das können
jetzt abschließend sagen meine damen und
herren als wir hatten coole sachen drin
mit den ich etwas anfangen kann also
irgendwie diese kohle harry boss und so
die sind ja auch ganz lecker das ist
ganz cool die taschenlampe finde ich
neues batterien weiß ich nicht ich
brauche nicht solche fetten batterien
dann hatte ich ihn noch so zwei komische
figürchen da weiß ich auch nicht aus
damit machen soll ein kleines büchlein
über die krippe eine menge menge papier
war darin eine menge verschiedene
batterien und technik so kleine sachen
von irgendwelchen riesigen maschinen
doppel das werde ich halt niemals
brauchen aber ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
habe halt 25 euro für sachen bezahlt die
wirklich insgesamt denke ich einen wert
von 50 euro haben
also das ist schon ganz neues hat die
burg dass ich mir eventuell noch einmal
so eine box bestellt aber dann
vielleicht für 50 euro das war meine
damen und herren wie zu beginn schon
gesagt falls ihr 50
schaffen solltet ihr aus eventuell serie
und dann kann ich dann auch demnächst
dann nicht 50 euro box kaufen sondern
vielleicht auch mal 300 euro für sonnen
box ausgeben und da muss dann richtig
geiler scheiß drin sein also wenn ich
mir halt überlege das jetzt hier in
einer 25 euro box sachen drin waren mit
einem gesamtwert von local die 70 80
euro das ist nach 300 euro box
lockerheit gesamtwert von 600 euro drin
also dass darauf hätte ich schon bock
also wie gesagt lasst leiter willi bock
drauf habt schreibt uns in die
kommentare und jetzt meine der